Hello and welcome to
YouTube Behind the Scenes
My name is Matias Molinas,
and I am a Google Developer
Expert for YouTube APIs.
In this lesson you will learn
how to use
the YouTube Data API
to manage and optimize
your YouTube channels
from your application.
As we saw in the first lesson,
the YouTube Data API
allows you to do
all the same operations you can
from your YouTube page,
but from your application.
For example,
you can manage playlists,
upload videos,
and search.
Today we will see an example
of how to use the Data API
to improve the performance
of your YouTube channels.
The API also allows you to manage
advanced features,
such as InVideo Programming,
which is one of the subjects
of today's lesson.
In this lesson we will see
the following subjects:
tricks and strategies
for optimizing your channel,
how to use Channel IDs,
how to manage lists,
InVideo Programming,
and the YouTube
Subscribe Button.
Are you ready?
Let's begin!
TRICKS AND STRATEGIES
FOR IMPROVING YOUR CHANNEL
Do you know
what YouTube users do?
They watch and share videos.
As mentioned in one of
the Google I/O sessions,
YouTube has more than a billion
individual users
that share
more than 700 videos per minute.
In the U. S., there are more men
between the ages of 18 and 34
participating than any
television channel.
This is why
your YouTube channel
is an excellent
means of communication
to reach a large audience.
Let's see some advice
as to how we can achieve this.
One way to do this is by
using titles, descriptions,
and Tags in your videos
that answer user questions
while using
the YouTube search engine.
An excellent strategy
is by making tutorial videos
that answer a question.
Let's look at a simple example:
a store that sells scarves
for your hair
with a video of techniques
of how to tie up your hair.
Maybe, for example,
for a store that sells
motorcycle helmets,
it would be a good idea
to upload a video
on how to choose a helmet size.
If you answer questions
that users might ask,
like "How to tie hair?,"
or, "How to choose
moto helmet?,"
then your videos will come up
in a good position
in the search results,
and new users
will discover your channel.
Then you need to convince them
to subscribe,
continue watching your videos,
and recommend them
to new users.
How do we do this first part?
Well, in the first lesson
we saw how to upload videos
to the channel
with the Data API.
In this case, we need
to carefully decide on
the title, the description,
and the Tags for the video,
so that they answer
the question the user
searches with.
When new users arrive
at your channel through a search
or because another user
shared a video with them
through a social network,
try to present them with content
that interests them
in subscribing to your channel.
One strategy you can use
to do this
is buy selecting and treating
the videos that appear
on your channel,
so that they are the most
popular to your audience.
In this lesson
we will see an example
of how we can do this
automatically.
We will see how to manage
your playlists
using the YouTube Data API.
In order to get audience
interest,
and get new users
to subscribe to your channel,
you can also use tools like
InVideo Programming,
which is another subject
we will look at in this lesson.
Finally, since what we want
is for users to subscribe
to your channel
so they can regularly watch
your content and share it
with people they know,
in the last subject
of this lesson we will see
what the YouTube
Subscribe Button is.
Before diving
into today's lesson,
I would like to give
some additional advice
that does not require you
to develop your own tools.
Post videos by chapter
and mention the chapter
in the video.
This way users
may get interested
and subscribe to your channel
to see the next chapters.
Remember that
the business owner
knows more than anyone
about their product.
This is a good strategy.
To take advantage of this,
make tutorials.
Users will find this content
very interesting.
Respond to the questions
and the comments
on your video and your channel.
Build a community.
Use Hangouts to interact
with your audience,
and to create and post videos
on your channel.
HOW TO USE CHANNEL IDs
On YouTube,
channels can be related
to YouTube user accounts
or Google+ profiles.
In the last example,
a profile can be a Google+ page.
We will see how to work
with channels
from our application code
considering these scenarios
where the channels
are not necessarily
related to a YouTube account.
Remember that all the operations
done with channels
with the Data API
use a Channel ID
to identify the channel.
STEP 1
WAYS TO OBTAIN THE CHANNEL ID
This is how you can obtain
the ID for the channel
that corresponds
to the user account.
If you are sure that the channel
is related to
a YouTube user account,
such as with
accounts prior to
Google+ integration,
then you can make
the following call
to the Data API
to obtain the Channel ID.
If you only know the name
of the channel shown on YouTube,
then you can obtain
the Channel ID
with the following search
through the Data API.
But, in this case,
you should be prepared
to deal with cases
when the search turns up
more than one result,
since the name of the channel
on YouTube
isn't necessarily unique.
STEP 2
OBTAIN DATA ABOUT CHANNEL
Once you obtain
the Channel ID,
you can obtain
all your channel data
using the Data API,
such as statistics
and brandingSettings.
To obtain the resource
for brandingSettings
for your channel,
and following prior examples,
you could use the following call
to the Data API.
These channel resources
include the following
useful data
to monitor channel performance
or change its appearance.
STEP 3
ACTUALIZE CHANNEL APPEARANCE
One feature that you
can actualize automatically
from the application
is the Channel Banner.
This image is used as an identity
and YouTube adapts it
to different devices for you.
You can use different criteria
to actualize and optimize
your Channel Banner.
I recommend you look at
the Google Analytics experiments,
which are an excellent resource
for presenting various
Banner options
to your users on a web page,
and by experiment results
through Google Analytics,
decide which is the best option
for your Banner.
Once you have
an optimal mechanism
for your Banner,
such as, for example,
the Google Analytics
experiments,
we will we how
you can use the results
to actualize
your Channel Banner.
There are only three steps.
Call channelBanners, then Insert.
This allows you to upload
binary data to YouTube
for a new image.
Be sure to check that this image
has an aspect ratio of 16:9
and at least 2048 x 1152 pixels.
Obtain the URL property
from the API reply
from the call made
during the last Step.
Call the channelUpdate method
to specify the corresponding URL
for the new banner
that you obtained in Step 2
in the brandingSettings property
Image, bannerExternalURL.
HOW TO MANAGE
PLAYLISTS
When new users
arrive at your channel,
you should try to show them
appealing content
That is, you should try to treat
your channel content,
playlists, and videos.
To do this, you need to
highlight and add
the videos with the most votes,
and remove the videos
with less activity.
This is a situation
where we can use
the YouTube Analytics Data API.
But, to make it easier,
we will only use the Data API
to organize the videos
from a list with the "likes."
Before seeing an example,
let's look at real examples
of channels
that treat their content,
and, thanks to this,
achieve excellent results.
We have the Gaturro channel,
PopartDiscos Argentina
or María Elena Walsh.
If you also want your channel
to present appealing content,
I suggest an example
where we can select
what videos to add
and what videos to remove
from a playlist
thereby making your channel
a lot more interesting.
STEP 1
CREATE A PLAYLIST
In the first step
we create a playlist
about a particular subject.
We are going to choose,
for example,
the Google Developers
Live videos,
but you can do the same
with your content,
that is, with your videos.
We are going
to create a playlist
about Google Developers
Live videos
on our channel.
STEP 2
ADD A VIDEO TO YOUR LIST
For the second step,
we are going to use
the Universal Search
to find videos on this subject
and add and organize them
by their number of "likes"
on our playlist.
Let's look at the code.
CHOOSE THE MOST POPULAR
AND ADD THEM TO YOUR LISTS
INVIDEO
PROGRAMMING
You have seen how to make
your channel more appealing
by treating the content
you present to your audience.
Now let's see how you can
promote your channel
by including appealing content
in each video.
This means, in the videos
shown on your channel
that are embedded
in a web page
or those shared in a post
on a social network.
In order to do this,
YouTube provides us
with a tool called:
InVideo programming.
This tool allows us to specify
a Watermark or a Miniature
with a link to a video.
This video should be appealing
and represent your channel.
You can program it to be seen
in all your videos
such as with annotations,
while checking that
it will be seen correctly
on all devices.
InVideo Programming also allows
you to create a link
to your social network pages
with a personalized message.
This way you can communicate
with your audience
through various
different ways.
You can actualize the watermark
or the video you use
with InVideo Programming,
and it will actualize
automatically
in all your videos,
without needing to actualize
or upload them again.
It's incredible,
but can we use this
from the Data API?
Yes, of course.
Let's look at some scenarios
where we will use these tools
from you application.
STEP 1
ACTUALIZE HIGHLIGHTED VIDEO
If your YouTube channel
is related to one on TV,
you can rotate the video you use
with InVideo Programming
so it changes
every day of the week,
on the weekends,
or according to the hour,
so it lines up
with your TV channel guide.
STEP 2
INTEGRATE OTHER CHANNELS
For the second step,
we will see
how to add a link
to your Twitter account
with InVideo Programming
to allow your audience to click
and continue the conversation
on another channel.
STEP 3
SIGN YOUR VIDEOS
You can use
InVideo Programming
to actualize the watermark.
The ideal way to do this,
and to optimize your channel,
is by doing it through
a Google Analytics experiment,
or with YouTube Analytics
experiments.
YOUTUBE SUSCRIBE BUTTON
We have seen tricks and advice
for creating content
that can be found
through searching on YouTube.
Then we saw how to treat
your playlists
to make your channel
more appealing.
Also, we saw how to use
InVideo Programming
to highlight your best content
and invite people
to subscribe to your channel.
Now let's see
how to use a Widget that,
from your web page,
allows them to subscribe.
The YouTube Subscribe Button
allows you to add a button
to subscribe to your channel
from any web page.
It also allows users
to subscribe to the channel
without having to leave
your web page.
STEP 1
ADD THE JAVASCRIPT LIBRARY
To add the button
on your web page,
include the following javascript
on the web page where you want
to add the subscription button.
STEP 2
CREATE YOUR BUTTON
You can add a button
with an element such as Div
and specifying a special class.
If you want, for example,
to create a subscription button
for the Google Developers
channel,
the necessary code
would be the following.
STEP 3
PERSONALIZE IT
You can personalize the button
by including a display
or by changing the theme.
You can also choose
by the number of
subscribers to your channel.
I hope you enjoyed this lesson.
We learned how to use
the Data API to,
from your application
or from your web page,
improve the performance
of your YouTube channel.
The goal is that new users
find your channel
through YouTube searches,
or through videos embedded
on a web page,
or videos shared
on social networks,
and then visit your channel
and find
treated and appealing content.
And, finally,
subscribe and become
part of your audience.
See you in the next lesson!